- There's a ton of terrible
medical advice online
but some of the worst has been on TikTok.
And by worst, I don't
always mean just inaccurate.
I mean, flat out dangerous.
Beewoop.
- Butter, Ragu.
- Don't go together.
- Get that thing in there.
Dip it, dip it, dip it.
- Aw, not only is that really not tasty,
the saturated fat inside
there, that's terrible.
The arteries are screaming, I feel it.
- Yo, this combo smack.
Y'all gotta try this.
- Smack what?
(blaring sound effect)
- [Narrator] How to stop
your period for an emergency.
- What?
- [Narrator] Two shots of
squeezed lime juice, tajin powder.
- What is tajin powder?
- [Narrator] Salt for flavor.
- Guys, I had to come
back to give you an update
because holy guacamole, it worked.
- No.
If it doesn't have hormones in it,
I don't understand how
it could possibly work.
The menstrual cycle does
experience regularities naturally.
Like if you travel, if you're
around other individuals,
you can actually see
fluctuations a few days apart.
It's not exact each month.
So, the fact that she
had a one day difference
in her menstrual cycle,
I don't think it's due to
this like, little tequila shot
or whatever it was that she took.
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, Synthol Guy.
Okay, so this is literally an oil
that you inject in order
to increase the size
of your muscle.
Bodybuilders sometimes use this.
Please don't do this.
You don't understand how dangerous this is
for your body.
Like, vasculitis, muscle
rupture, infection
and it's also ridiculous looking.
I don't know if you see this.
- Haters will say it doesn't work.
I'm convinced that if you put
a base sunscreen of SPF 30 on
and then SPF 90 on all the spots
that you would put highlighter on,
the sun will contour your face
where you'd put bronzer
and you'll be naturally
snatched the whole summer.
- Check this out.
You could put high SPF
everywhere on your face
and prevent it from aging prematurely.
Keep your skin healthy, non-sunburn
and then you could put makeup
and make yourself as beautiful
and highlighter and shaped
and snatched as you wish to be.
- Five organs, five exercises
to help you restore those organ functions.
- Please be medically accurate.
Please.
- Heart: you're gonna pound the inside.
These are the nerves that
are connected to your heart.
- These are the nerves that
These are the- this is the skin.
This is the muscle
and there are nerves here
that are not connected to your heart.
What are we even talking about right now?
(blaring sound effect)
- Slap your arm, slap it.
- Slap it, slap it.
You know what's a good
exercise for your heart?
This is for your spleen and your stomach.
- The spleen is not a
digestive organ. (laughs)
- Gonna do the thrust for your kidneys.
Thrust for your kidneys.
- What?
Just drink enough water.
Stay well hydrated, sleep
well, get some exercise
and eat some plants and vegetables.
You don't need to thrust.
(techno music)
What?
Is this a stretch?
I guess she's using the dumbbells
in order to keep the legs stretched out.
I actually have a lot of pain
in that area when I stretch.
So, maybe I need to
improve my flexibility.
But remember, too much flexibility
is not always the answer
and overstretching can
actually be a problem.
- Drinking sparkling water
isn't considered water.
(blaring sound effect)
- What?
- Definition of water
is fish must swim in it.
- Okay this is-
this is a Saturday night live skit.
- Sparkling water is not high sodium,
but it is- has a deep mineral content.
- Deep- the depth of its mineral
content makes it not water.
- So, best bet is always water first.
Definition of water is
fish must swim in it.
- Water first is a fine mantra,
but fish must swim in it
is ridiculous because
fish swim in salt water
and if you drink salt water, oh boy,
you're gonna be in for some troubles.
- So, I decided to go get a colonic.
Don't ask me the scientific definition.
- The scientific definition is
that you don't need a colonic.
That's like, the end of it.
- Oh my gosh.
This hurts so bad.
- It hurts?
Don't do it.
They are dangerous.
There is no benefit to them.
People think it cleanses them out.
No, your body is a
natural cleansing system.
The surface of your intestines
regularly sheds and leaves.
You don't have like, poop
buildup that sits in there
for years on end.
(hammer slamming)
(man wincing)
I have a feeling this guy's
Russian 'cause he said oi
and that's like a Russian thing,
but why is he hitting him?
Did he do something mean to his family?
(speaking in foreign language)
This is insane.
He's hitting him with a
mallet and a piece of wood
on a napkin.
This goes to show how BS this is.
So, he palpates the spine
and then all of a sudden
he lifts his hands off
and then randomly applies the little pad
and the wooden thing.
My man, you already let go
and you already don't
see where you palpated.
You're making it up.
You're lying.
(man wincing)
Honestly, this is a crime.
I've never gone as far as
saying that on a TikTok
or any medical reaction video,
this is a full-on crime.
- There's a big difference.
You do not inhale cigars, okay?
It's just a puff, it never
goes into your lungs.
- Okay, that is just
like, factually untrue.
There's smoke all around
you that you're inhaling.
In fact, second hand and third hand smoke
is really dangerous from cigars.
Cigars can even be more
dangerous than cigarettes.
Chances of getting certain
types of cancers go up
four to 10 fold.
So no, they are not safer than cigarettes.
That's just a complete myth.
- You put garlic up your nose,
it's supposed to cleanse your sinuses.
- No, they don't cleanse your sinuses
'cause they're garlic.
- So far, there's a little
bit of snot trailing out
around the nostril holes.
- So, if you're sick,
you have snot and that's what's happening.
- I feel a lot of
congestion right up in here.
- Because you plugged
your nose with the garlic.
(girl blowing nose)
Yeah, that's all the snot
that would have come out
had she not put those in there.
It's an irritant to
your nasal passageways.
You don't need to do that.
If you want to clear your
snot out, use nasal saline.
This is a complete myth.
It just does not work.
- Hey, what you doing?
Dude, I need to pee so bad
but these people have been
in here for like 45 minutes.
- 45 minutes?
Might want to look
elsewhere for a bathroom.
- You should start thinking about sex.
Really, come on.
No dude, I'm being serious.
It tricks your brain and
relieves some of the pressure.
- Distraction when you need to pee
and you can't go in
that given moment works.
Whether you think about that,
whether you think about
what's going on next week,
will distract you
and allow you to think
about something else.
- Oh, these migraines kill me.
Come on, stick your hands in
this ice water, it'll help.
No, just let me die.
Ice water.
Okay, fine, fine.
- Ice for migraines has been tested
and has found some relief
and success in some patients.
To me, it's like a low risk thing.
As long as you're not
doing any harm to your body
and it can take some of that pressure off
and the headache pain down, by all means.
That's like a really low
risk way to try and do that.
- Did you know that all the top athletes
are not drinking this stuff?
- What?
- Because I found out that
Gatorade is actually very,
very acidic.
- You have lemon flavor Gatorade.
- This right here actually
promotes inflammation,
promotes aging and it promotes injury
because once the body goes
acidic, it cannot heal.
(alarm blaring)
- The body keeps a very
tight range of its pH,
very tight, 7.35 to 7.45.
If it starts gently
coming out of that range
and becoming more acidic, even
slightly, it could be lethal.
So, drinking Gatorade does
not make your body go acidic
because if it drops
your pH to below seven,
every time you have a
Gatorade, you would be dead.
That's why health gurus
really frustrate me
and confuse the life out of me
because on one hand they
tell you to take antioxidants
like vitamin C because they
say they're so good for you.
On the other hand, they tell
you to avoid acid of any kind,
because it's so dangerous.
Do you know what vitamin C is?
It's asorbic acid.
(computer sounding)
- Do you have a stuffy, congested toddler?
I'm gonna show you how to clear them out.
Blow out of one side of their nostril.
Make sure their mouth is shut.
Hold her mouth, blow.
- Moms are so creative.
Cute video, not the
method I would recommend.
Use a suction tool, like a bulb.
Pushing it out sometimes carries risk.
You're moving bacteria around the airway.
The child can choke on the snot.
Plus, remember your mouth
has a bunch of bacteria in it
that you're putting
into your child's mouth.
So, suction is always
better in this scenario
than blowing air in.
This technique does work sometimes.
Breathing in a child's mouth.
If your child has something
stuck in their nostril,
closing the other nostril,
breathing into the child's mouth.
For me, if something's
stuck in your child's nose,
go to the ER, like that's
the safest way to get it out.
(techno music)
That looks like a keloid scar.
Basically a keloid is,
after you get any kind
of damage to your skin,
cuts, punctures, et cetera,
you could actually form excess collagen
in the form of a keloid like this.
It does happen in younger
people more often,
like ages ten to 30.
Darker skinned individuals
have 10 to 20% higher
rates of this as well.
- Why does a hot bath burn more belly fat
than jogging for an hour?
- It doesn't.
- Imbalanced hormones.
What?
(kettle whistling)
(exploding effect)
Hey, my name is Dr. Jade Tita
and you're probably thinking to yourself,
what is a big burly linebacker
looking guy like me-
- My man, have you seen a linebacker.
(crowd raving sound effect)
- Women looking to lose weight,
especially in their midsection,
may want to pay more attention
to foods and activities
that balance hormones
based on their unique hormone type.
- And he's gonna sell you exactly
what their unique hormone
type can benefit from.
- Take my unique hormone type quiz
because a hormone type two
needs a different approach.
- A hormone type two that I just made up.
- Then a hormone type six.
(alarm sound effect)
- My man said type six,
what happened to one, three,
four, and five and seven?
I want to be smart enough as a doctor
to come up with my own hormone types.
(rhythmic music)
You definitely want to sanitize the area
before you do any kind of micro-needling.
That's smart.
If you're gonna be making
abrasions in your skin
so much can go wrong,
especially on the face.
I just wouldn't trust a random device
bought off the internet.
- Kind of felt like getting a tattoo.
Had only a couple spots that
bled just a teeny tiny bit.
- People really trust these things.
Being a family medicine doctor,
not a plastic surgeon or a dermatologist,
When a patient comes in
with even a small laceration
that requires sutures on the face
I'm always hesitant to do it
because I want to make sure
that it's as less scarring
as possible happening.
So, I let someone with a
lot more experience do it.
These people are just like,
doing micro-needling on
themselves with no fear.
(upbeat music)
Oh, not ear candling.
There's a warning from
the FDA to not do this.
(upbeat music)
So, this is BS because
this has been tested
and we actually see no suction happening
as a result of the flame.
We also see that that is residue
of the actual paraffin wax or beeswax
that is inside this candle thing
because we see this same
residue on these candles
that have not been put into ears.
On top of that, do you know
how many of my colleagues
have treated burns from
this ear wax nonsense?
Oh my god!
- Life-saving advice from movies
that can actually kill you.
According to Hollywood,
if someone has passed out with no pulse,
you should straddle them,
give them mouth to mouth
and beat on their chest.
- Yeah, don't beat on people's chest.
Don't give them mouth to
mouth, if someone's passed out,
all you have to do is chest compressions,
chest compressions, chest compressions.
- I'm not saying CPR doesn't work,
but it only works like two
to four percent of the time
and when properly performed,
you usually end up cracking
the person's rib cage.
- My man is confused here
because he's saying
pounding on their chest
versus performing chest
compressions is both CPR.
Factually untrue.
The purpose of performing CPR
is not to bring someone
back, it's to buy time
so other interventions can be done,
like giving them
medications like epinephrin
or perhaps bringing a defibrillator along
because the reason you're
pumping on someone's chest
is to circulate the blood
that's already in their body
that has some oxygen still left in it
and the breaking of the ribs, no big deal.
Why?
Because the person is already dead.
So, if you can extend their possibility
of being brought back to life
by breaking a rib, fair
trade-off, wouldn't you say?
Beating up misinformation
or beating up other boxers,
click here.
Announcing my boxing career
right there, click it.
I'm a serious boxer, getting
better with each day.
Who's going to be my first fight.
Leave a link down below,
leave a comment down below.
Don't know what I'm saying.